[Musique]
le département de La Réunion et le
groupe Bernard Ayot ont signé ce jeudi
14 décembre un accord de partenariat
pour favoriser l'insertion des jeunes
éloigné de l'emploi en 2021 à la Réunion
41000 jeunes de 15 à 29 ans ne sont ni
en emploi ni en études ni en formation
ces jeunes représentent 26 % de leur
classe d'âge soit deux fois plus qu'au
niveau
national je salue le partenariat entre
le groupe GBH et nous-même ce
partenariat va permettre à des dizaines
de jeunes réunonnés d'être bien
accompagné pour intégrer le monde du
travail parce que quand gne un
travail derrière c'est le projet de vie
que peut réaliser c'est pour cela que le
département en lien avec pas l'emploi en
lien avec d'autres partenaires nous
mettons en place ce type d'action pour
faire que le jeune trouve un emploi et
que l'entreprise qui recrute trouve des
jeunes qu
c'est ça le but de ce partenariat GBH un
des plus grands employeurs sur le
territoire a lancé son programme
trempelin pour l'emploi avec l'école de
la deuxième chance et poursuit
aujourd'hui son engagement pour réduire
ses
inégalités TPE c'est un dispositif a
créé GBH pour résumer et intégrer toutes
les actions de formation solidaire que
l'on fait en faveur des populations
éloigné de l'emploi et en l'occurrence
les jeunes puisque vous savez que c'est
un vrai sujet à la Réunion et donc dans
ce cadre là nous avons décidé de
d'initier une nouvelle formation avec le
département donc TPE GBH département
afin de favoriser le retour à l'emploi
de jeunes
défavorisés dans le cadre du plan
d'action 2023 2024 adopté en mars 2023
par le Conseil départemental en faveur
de la réussite des jeunes GBH va
collaborer étroitement avec la cellule
insertion par l'innovation rattachée à
la Direction de la Jeunesse et des
Sports concrètement c'est partenariat
hyper important puisque les jeunes qui
sont dans cette cellule d'innovation au
niveau du département vont pouvoir grâce
à cette convention intégrer les
entreprises du groupe AOT à la Réunion
comme on le sait qui un groupe très
important dans sous la forme soit
d'immersion en entreprise c'est-à-dire
voir comment ça se passe dans une
entreprise concrètement sous forme
d'emploi également puisqu'il y a des
embauches directs qu'ell soit en CDB ou
ou en CDI ou de manière temporaire mais
également dans l'autre sens c'est-à-dire
que les professionnels du groupe AOT
s'engage à venir de manière très
ponctuelle dans les ateliers
d'accompagnement que vont mener les
professionnels du département à
témoigner de leur expérience de leur
expertise et de leur conseils auprès de
ces jeunes qui cherchent encore pour la
plupart leur orientation
professionnelle ce partenariat témoigne
de l'engagement commun en faveur de la
jeunesse et de la volonté partager de
créer des opportunités significatives
pour les jeunes en difficulté
d'insertion
professionnelle